I mean look at what we did with NATO how
we pushed it right up to the Russian
border and then blamed them for for
moving forward like it's like putting
turrets right you were yeah putting a
bunch of turrets right outside someone's
front door you know what I don't think
any of it is serious because these
aren't serious people including the
people who are running our military
people who are in charge here and
everywhere else they're just not serious
they're not capable people are you
saying that you don't think we're being
serious
to do what beyond what he's already
doing
I love this meme I don't think he wants
to invade the US no he doesn't I I agree
with that or I don't think he wants to
invade Poland I don't think he wants an
invade anywhere this is a good example
of us thinking that the Iranians are a
threat Iranians are a threat to the
United States it's a meme where it says
Iran wants war look how close they put
their country to our military bases and
then it shows all of the US military
bases surrounding Iran yeah I don't
think that the United States is at any
threat to anyone but themselves at this
point well the U.S is a threat to a lot
of people around the world